[Music]
one of the apprehensions that people
have about this technological
singularity which is really a metaphor
the metaphor borrowed from physics to
describe what happens when you go
through a black hole center of a black
hole the singularity the laws of physics
as we know them kind of collapse or
implode they no longer apply a great
metaphor that we borrow to use to
describe what can happen with technology
we're going to hit this inflection point
the singularity where it's going to be
like a runaway train builds on itself
and the Terminator scenario is that this
artificially artificial intelligence
this algorithm is going to wake up it's
going to achieve symptoms and it's going
to turn on us but that's I think an
erroneous way of looking at it some of
the more optimistic futurists in Silicon
Valley including people like Kurzweil
and Kevin Kelly for example who wrote
what technology wants say that what's
going to happen instead is that we're
going to continue to augment our own
thinking by uploading more and more and
more of our own cognition or cognitive
apparatus to non-biological intelligence
so it's not so much that that mind is
going to ride that artificial - and rise
up against us but that we're going to
continue to become more non-biological
in other words we already offload
cognition on to non-biological props
when you write something down on a piece
of paper part of your thinking is
happening on that paper part of your
thinking is happening by you moving your
hand on that pen part of your thinking
is occurring when you stare at the
contents of your own mind on that paper
and reflect on what you wrote
we already incorporate non-biological
aspects into our thinking apparatus
there's a great essay written by these
cognitive philosophers called David
Chalmers and Andy Clark cognitive
philosophers called the extended mind
thesis which says that things like an
iPhone or a smartphone are already
manifestations and extensions of the
mind and that the mind is actually not
limited to the brain but that the mind
exists in the feedback loops between
brains tools and environments so that
that's why we say our thoughts shape our
spaces and our spaces return the favor
that's why they say that everything we
design is designing
in return Marshall McLuhan used to say
we build the tools and the tools build
us so what really exists our feedback
loops feedback loops of mind it's not us
versus them it's all one large
distributed intelligence that has
biological and on biological parts
that's why I don't think that we have
anything to be afraid of
it's just billions of baby steps that
increasingly extend an augment or
creative capacity
[Music]
you
[Music]